ます
あなたはヨーグルトが好きですか
日本ではこんな形の容器に入ったヨーグルトが売られていません
こんなヨーグルトが好きだというかば良かったらでは寝てるん
たそのままでてほしいんですがでものヨーグルト食べるときフタの裏についている
ヨーグルト食べちゃう
美味しいありがとうございます
そうここ美味しいんですよ
私も必ず食べん
なぜでしょ
なぜ-はヨーグルト2問裏に惹かれてしまうのでしょうか
希少かってぃという言葉があります
ビジネスにおいて希少価値とあ
非常に大事なことの一つです
なぜだろう
市場に流通する数が少ないものは
高い値段でやりとりすることができるからです
なんとなくわかりましたっ
あなたはこんな経験はないですかお店に入っ
今年の新作だよとか
期間限定商品だよと言われて
予算オーバーだけどついつい買ってしまうこと
それが希少価値数の少ないもの
私たちは惹かれてしまうんです
ではいい
少数派の意見に高い価値があるか
と問われるとどうでしょうか
時に少数派6県とはないが種用意されたり無視されたり
することが多いのではないでしょうか
私は幼い頃から少数派な人間でした
なぜかというと私算数が大好きなん
数が大好きな女の子がなぜ少数派なのか
それは私が小学生の頃なんですが
小学校にクラスメイトの雰囲気が
こんな感じだった皆さんも自分が小学生だった頃を思い出してほしいですが
好きな科目ってなんでしたか
タイプっ
もっと
給食
もはやそれは科目ジャム
私は幼い頃から体が細くて食も細くて
そんなクラスメイトの大多数のうん意義に生まれて
算数がスキッとは大きな声で言えなかったんです
周りを見て私はもしかして周りとちょっと違うおかしい
恥ずかしい
そう思ってなかなか人前で算数がスキーということができずにいました
でも好きなのはやめられませんから
二中学校高等をどんどん
算数の魅力にのめり込んでいくんですが
大学生のある日家庭教師のアルバイトを始めたんです
そしたら
算数が苦手な小学生や中学生の生徒さんがたくさんいました
そして a
できるは若くて女の先生に算数教えてほしいな
そんなことを言うセプターも
そう私は
数が好きな女子だったからこそ
周りの家庭教師の同様よりちょっと
より多くの生徒の指示を受けてちょっと多くの給料をもらうことができたんです
さらに続きがあって私は大学卒業した後
em 事情もあってホテルで働き始めます
ご存知でしたかホテルで働いている方の多くが
ホテルサービスの専門学校や
商業化でサービス基本を勉強してきているんです
私は私は大学で応用数学やネットワークテクノロジーを勉強してきてますから
こんな常識的なことも知らない音
同様に言われることもありました
でも負けてはいられませんから
1私にしかできる私にしかできないことがあるはず
そう思って a
まあいろいろシクを避けましたその時に沸騰
手元の携帯電話に目がとまりましたいっ
私経済年はとかガジェットが大好き
そうだ
携帯電話に充電器を集めよう
そして
宿泊したお客さんが自由に使えるようにしたらいい
お客さんが happy になろうじゃないか
私にとって携帯電話の充電器を集めることはそう難しいことではありません
携帯電話各社に回っていろんな携帯電話の充電器を買ってそして
エクセルで十分日貸出やってます
あなたの使っている携帯電話の充電器が必ずあります
そんなキャッチコピーをつけていっ
それから wi-fi の環境も整えました
イミヌはもう珍しくないサービスですが
その頃温泉旅館でそこまでやっているホテルはありませんでした
あのホテルはちょっと違うサービスが受けられるらし
そして
お客様からたくさんの支持を得ることができたんです
逆境の立場でありながら自分にしかできないことがきっとあるはず
そう思いながら
私なりにホテルの仕事にやりがいを見出し
頑張っていました
そうなる日私市場計算外の大事件が起こります
2011年3月11日
東日本大震災
日本全国に重たくって悲しい空気が流れて
そして
誰しも考えたと思います
自分の生まれ日生まれ故郷のこと
大切な家族のことそして
かけがえのない命のほど
私の命は一つしかありません私の人生も一つしかありません
一度しか前人生で後悔したくないん
私は何が好きだっ
もっと
算数を楽しみたいテクノロジーを楽しみたい
私はプログラマーとしての一歩を歩み始めます
震災から2週間を
3月25日私は会社に辞表を出しました
花キャラクプログラマへ転身を遂げた私ですがやはりそこでもうまくはいきません
なぜなら
システムエンジニアとして入社した今の会社には
同い年だけど自分よりも好きリヤ
経験が豊富な同僚がいたんですん
さらに女性のエンジニアというのはまだまだ少数派
涙を流すこともありました
一生懸命辺の申しましたでもやっぱり
スキルや経験は同様にかなわないんです
ホテルの仕事してたもんなぁ
寄り道してたからかなぁ
そう思って私は同僚に引け目を感じながら日々過ごしていました
そんなある日お客黒の前で商品説明をする機会を与えてもらいました
プログラムの世界は専門要望のオンパレードでシステマチックで1奪ですごくわかり
にくい世界なので
できるだけ株価6言葉やグラフに表してお客様で一生懸命説明を
説明会は何とかなうまくこなせたんですが
その帰り道同僚から思いがけない言葉を掛けてもらったんです
開発者にしては
目がすごく上手いねっ
それは女の子は違うそんなこと言われたんん
その言葉をキープ塾も本当に体が震えるほど嬉しかったんです
人と話す仕事接客業をしていたことは
寄り道だと思っていたでもそうじゃなかった
接客業をしていた私の経験は今
それぞれのスキルとして自分の武器になっているのだと気づいたんです
自分が少数派の立場に
パッドとき
人は恥ずかしいとか間違っているんじゃないかと思ってしまいがちです
でもちょっと見方を変えたらそれはー
自分が大好きなものを追い求めてたどり着い酒っから
ん
少数派の立場なんだったらそれはもしかしたら
他の周りの誰にも負けない武器を手に入れるチャンスだと思いませんか
ありがとうございます
ます